next i've got my trusty air
what's up gq i'm camila cabello and
these are my essentials
[Music]
you have no idea who i'm looking at
right now
so
my first item will be it's kind of two
items but i think of it
as one so i always have a book that i'm
reading right now i'm reading braiding
sweetgrass and i'm right here and it's a
book about indigenous wisdom scientific
knowledge and the teachings of plants by
robin wall
timmer and it's already like i think
probably my favorite book i've ever read
it makes me feel really grounded and i
also always have a book that i haven't
started because if i'm on the plane
or if i'm somewhere usually i'll have
another book if i'm closer to the end
but if i finish i want to have another
book
already ready for me wherever i am i've
tried kindles and i've tried reading on
my ipad as well i guess if it was a
conscious like sustainability like
environmental thing i would
move to a kindle or an ipad but i'm kind
of old school in that i love the feeling
of a book no
technology just me and like the words
that somebody wrote
[Music]
this is kind of like my
singing goodies i've got um this manuka
honey
which is so delicious it's actually like
dessert when i have it right now
[Music]
so good
just honey
throw coat
singers necessities
grether's pastilles
also singer necessities
and this is a brand new box
of entertainer secret spray and this i
will use if i like the other day i did
james corden uh crosswalk the musical
and i just had absolutely no voice and
that is like the most stressful
situation ever for a singer when you
have to sing and you're like it's not
coming out and this is kind of like a
little miracle i don't use it all the
time but dry throat and hoarse voice and
it just will kind of throat what coat
toe coat so that's my little
singer's pouch
which i don't have with me all the time
because i don't sing every day
and thank god because i lose my voice a
lot
i really like this water because it's
waterific this is like a super
sustainable company and uh it's not
plastic i'm slowly kind of looking at my
life and being like how can i make
choices that are more environmentally
conscious and sustainable especially
with the climate crisis and things that
we're experiencing nowadays so if i can
have like two of these in a day
then that's really good i would just
never drink water i don't know how i
like survived honestly
[Music]
i call this little lady
actually i don't know if she's a lady i
think she's non-binary gender-neutral
sometimes i call her miss patty
sometimes i call her patty people think
it's funny the relationship i have with
my ipad i got it during the pandemic
because i had this obsession with
reading articles
and i love reading the new york times
and the new yorker and and i don't have
any social media on my ipad it's purely
recreational sketching stuff even though
i'm not good at it or youtube i use it
for studio sessions a lot and i collect
stickers and i put it on patty and
whenever i lose patty my friends make
fun of me because i'll always be like
patty
where are you
so i have a very close relationship with
my ipad it's brought me a lot of joy and
a lot of knowledge
next i've got my trusty air
i don't lose sunglasses but i lose
freaking air pods this is a really bad
habit of mine i think it's because
especially on planes like i will take
them off and then i'll fall asleep and
then they'll fall through the cracks of
the seats and i can't find them and sean
always gets mad at me because i always
steal his air pods and i'll rename them
like camila
then i'll be like these aren't your
airpods they say camila's airpods and
he's like that's because you renamed
them and i'm like touche so this one is
it's my airpods but i have lost one what
am i listening to right now i'm very
late to things so sometimes something
will be popping and i will discover how
good it is like two years later
and i just listened to jojo cat's uh her
album which i'm a huge fan of and i
listen to a lot of a lot of latin music
a lot of cetangana
a lot of bad bunny right now a lot of
reikithon sometimes i go in just like
these moments of uh just like being in a
cave when it comes to pop culture and i
don't know what's going on and then i'll
emerge and i'll be like guys doji cat is
amazing and they're like yeah we know
[Music]
i also want to show you these because
they're they're dirty and clearly i walk
around barefoot a lot because they're
kind of like you can see like
my feet my feet dirt especially when i'm
working try to bring some flip-flops
with me because i am a chancellor which
is kind of very long for like a
flip-flopper which uh means that i'm
from miami and i just am in flip-flops
there like 100 of the time gotta have
some flip-flops especially if you're
like going to a party or a dinner and
you're like okay now i'm ready to take
these heels off it's just there's no
shame in just
whipping one of these out
my next item i've got some sunglasses i
like to uh have a pair of sunglasses
with me
especially here in l.a like in miami i
maybe wouldn't but here there's like
paparazzi and like stuff and also
sometimes it's just too damn bright out
there i always bring some sunglasses to
match whatever outfit i'm wearing this
doesn't really match but it is what it
is this is a prive prive revo which i
think haley steinfeld worked with this
brand of sunglasses and i think they
they sent
these to me and i like that they're just
like full coverage
if i'm hungry like i don't want to just
like reach for like some chips i'd
rather reach for something healthy like
a trail mix this one is like one of my
favorites it's from air one and it's got
like cashews it's got uh goji berry it's
got dark chocolate and it's got walnuts
so it's very strong 10 out of 10
and also this hue uh dark chocolate it's
just so good dark chocolate also has a
bit of caffeine doing promo or whatever
and i'm like i don't want to have coffee
but i need some caffeine i'll just be
like give me the chocolate now
[Music]
lip gloss
oh my god it smells so good and i uh
usually have like a lip gloss or
lipstick or whatever matches with
whatever i'm wearing that day so today
it's
this i always have a charger with me
because i can't tell you how many times
i've been somewhere and my phone dies
and i have to go into a store and be
like do you guys have a charger can i
please charge my phone if this was
before i could drive too like i needed
an uber so i'd be like i'm literally
stranded without my phone like this is
not good mophie or portable chargers see
that i lose all the time i don't know
it's just easier for me to just bring a
cord and like a little uh
it's a box
charging cube wow see charging cube i
don't know
that was what it was called um so i
bring that and i'll just plug it
wherever i am
[Music]
guys thank you so much for checking out
my essentials um i'll see you next time